[Music]
good morning John it's Monday June 25th
and I don't have time to talk to you
right now I'm sorry I'm finishing the
book dum dee dum dee dum dee reading a
book o
da de dum de dum dum dee dum dee dum dum
dee dum dee dum dee reading a book John
I've been meaning to ask you something
I guess it's pretty normal for adults to
write books for kids but is it normal
for adults to read books for kids I know
you do it but you can call it research
but I read books for kids cuz I like
books for kids me not usually books for
kids as much as books for young people
I'm fairly certain that this book was
written for kids but it's really good I
get a lot the worst thing is when I read
books for adults
I often really don't like them very much
I'm honestly not sure what the
difference is like I've read a lot of
adult books that have really young main
characters person who lives in that
house right over there
and her book the main character was 13
but the book was marketed at adults in
this book the main character is 12 but
the book is marketed at 12 year olds to
me it seems like the only real
difference is that that book was a lot
more believable and this book is a lot
more fun I'll notice that I've decided
to record the three walk in my front
yard this is part of a project of mine I
got really comfortable making video
blogs downstairs so comfortable impact
that I was screaming and yelling at the
camera I was really excited all the time
and people were commenting on that and
they were excited by it but the fact was
I could only be like that in my basement
so last video I went into my side yard
where people couldn't see me because
there's a fence around it and I tried to
be myself and be exuberant in my sign
yard and today I'm moving into my front
yard where people can see me because
there are roads all around me and no
fences and the idea is that I will soon
be able to be my video blogging self in
places with lots of people and slowly I
can move further and further away from
my basement while still making
and still not being really preoccupied
with the fact that there might be a car
driving by or a person on a bike looking
at me or a neighbor looking out of their
house wondering what the heck their
neighbor is doing sitting in his front
yard talking at a camera which is
sitting on top of a stool I needed a
tripod I'm basing the strategy on how
we've trained our cat to take walks
first we just took her onto the back
porch and then we took her into the side
yard and then we took her onto the
sidewalk and then we took her into the
front yard and now she can pretty much
go to the front yard that's as far as
she's gonna get I think she doesn't like
going anywhere else so I'm gonna try and
break past that barrier that cameo can't
seem to break through I don't know if
I'm gonna make it but I'm gonna try now
John I hope you're okay with me leaving
you to do whatever you're doing because
right now I have to read my book black
John I will see you tomorrow oh my god
stop bothering me reading
and congratulations to nerdfighter
Ashley Elle on her marriage today
getting married on a Monday that's kind
of weird mom gratulations